[Music]
we're going to go to robert in knoxville
tennessee robert welcome to the ramsey
show
hey good morning thank you for taking my
call absolutely afternoon
that's all right time flies when we're
having fun how can i help today
i have a question of uh should i do it
i'm 59 i have no debt no car loans no
student loans oh about 65 000 on the
house
and my wife's car is close to 18 years
old i've been paid off for a good 10
years at least
and
if my money market account is getting
one half of one percent
and a car loan is going to be expected
to be four and a half five percent
shouldn't i just take it out of savings
and go ahead and pay off the car in full
just be done with it and uh technically
i'm saving four and a half percent right
are you saying to pay for the car in
cash or are you saying you're wanting to
take out a loan
pay for the car in cash that's what i'm
thinking i should do oh and you're
saying well it's normal for people to
just take out a car loan
and you're saying why would i do that
at four and a half percent
i don't yeah i mean we're in the boat of
i don't care what the interest rate is
if it's one percent or 70 we think it's
dumb to take on any debt of any kind and
that you're better off paying cash for
it especially a depreciating asset like
a car
so you got the right mentality around it
what's this car uh gonna cost
uh forty thousand it's a user mercedes
okay
are you guys three years old anyway
yeah what's your household income
uh about eighty five thousand uh we've
got about two hundred thousand in each
other savings account plus
another
350 and two other retirement accounts
and i have a fully funded emergency fund
that
is 60 000 just sitting there hold on
you've got 200 000 in cash
oh in the bank sure
and you
have a 65 000 mortgage
yes is it a pet why are you keeping it
around pay this thing off today
i was planning on doing that in early
2022 but why not late 2021
because the
car was the question
the older car 17 18 years old is getting
older and but you got the money to do
both you could pay off the car and buy
that mercedes today
you could pay off the mortgage
at 59 i've probably got another good
eight years before i retire right
okay
but you've got this money in liquid cash
yes so the question is why are you
holding on to the mortgage
well true too nice point
i mean i if i'm you i want to be debt
free baby step seven living and giving
like no one else today
you guys have worked really hard to to
have all this big pile of money and it's
not working very hard for you when
you're sitting there paying a lender
every month
right
so what do you say okay you pay off the
mortgage today
uh do you have any other vehicles
currently
uh yes have a uh
an old seven uh i don't know chevy
cobalt but that hey
no joke i had i had an 07 chevy cobalt
still runs i think i think i'm talking
to my future self hopefully are you a
millionaire
is your net worth
what is your net worth
oh off the top of my head maybe a half a
million
okay
well i mean it's an expensive car uh
based on your income we we have kind of
a parameter that your everything with a
motor in it should add up to no more
than half of your income and so you're
edging up close to it you're not in
terrible financial shape obviously so
you're okay but i wouldn't go any any
crazier than that car right now
okay and you do have a pile of money so
it makes me feel a whole lot better
about this but uh is the mortgage your
only debt
yes sir man i'm getting rid of that
thing
today and i'm gonna be on the car lot
tomorrow and i'm gonna be driving away
with that mercedes and you're still
gonna have plenty of money sitting in
cash in the bank
are you guys on track for retirement
i believe so yes because it sounds like
you're heavily weighted in liquid cash
and not a ton in retirement
investing right now is that right
i got two retirement accounts through
various jobs
okay but they they don't add up to more
than a half million total without all of
your assets
no those two are only about uh about 180
to 225 000. yeah that's my only caveat
here is you don't have a ton in
retirement right now if you plan on
retiring soon so i wouldn't if i'm you
i'm i'm taking a pause here and going
okay let me what's best for my financial
future in retirement is it buying a 40
000 car that's going to depreciate in
value or should i really be focused on
building that retirement nest egg so
that i can retire at 65.
okay
i gotta wait till 67 don't i
no you don't have to wait
no absolutely i mean what are you
waiting till 67 for
because i like my work i guess oh well
you can keep working but i want to make
sure that you've got enough money to
live on in retirement when you decide i
like to have options i don't know about
you robert but i want to be able to
retire when i want to and not when i
have to so there's no law saying you
have to retire 67 you can work to your
85. i think dave ramsey will he just
loves to work but he could also stop
working today and it'd be no issue
all right
man
sorry you're in a good you're gonna in a
good spot robert but uh i would be
questioning this retirement savings
before i jump on this 40 000 car you got
this pile of money i might invest that
money and let it grow so that you've got
a big old retirement nest egg but you've
done a really really good job and i want
to see all this mortgage uh paid off you
got this man this is the ramsay show